in terms of when you look at doing
projects in Detroit and sort of building
us out the projects of a design very
much to be jobs and to center around
economic opportunity and expanding that
and making these neighborhoods a
revitalization where people can walk to
work or that they still have easier
access or that you know it starts with a
family it starts with a home it starts
with a job is that replicatable do you
think on a much broader scale just even
just the lessons that you're taking out
of Detroit yeah I mean if you travel
around the world and I get this to
travel around the world and see all
these things Singapore does it it's a
country when it when it form it was part
of Malaysia but it formed it was
partially Chinese partially Malay
partial Indian and in speak each other's
languages a prime minister came in with
the same kind of vision and strength to
get it done is its GDP is now higher
than than the GDP of the average
American okay the Prime Minister is
pretty tough he made them all or in
English so it could become a back office
for companies he made sure the streets
were clean when he did they have a lot
of affordable housing he but he made
sure that they that you you couldn't
live like it wasn't an Indian building
and a Malay building a Chinese building
he desegregated not just by building and
that's just by floor by apartment he
wanted them to know each other's kids
and smell each other's foods and stuff
like that I tell people and you put some
of my Liberal Democratic friends
responsible to Singapore it would still
be a backwater oh you can't force people
to live where they don't want to live
you can't you know you can't punish
people for spitting on the streets you
can't make people in English that's what
would happen and so people have to think
policy pot what works and what doesn't
work and so and by same thing with other
countries I just mentioned Germany's
vocational schools and Germany's doing
well in Europe and most of the country
countries aren't so you learn these
things when you go around the world
about what works and what doesn't and
you can write them and there have been
books written about Venezuela Ecuador
Argentina Cuba North Korea what did they
do and largely populism and you know the
ones that worked and South Korea no
natural resources
unbelievable story Singapore no natural
resources unbelievable story so I mean I
can go on and on and on about what works
and what doesn't and you know for some
ways you know one of these lessons I I
worry about bad public policy just
causing constant
image out there and you know beat when
in America you keep on hearing no
productivity's low its secular
stagnation it's a new normal
it's just not true okay we've we've had
multiple Wars okay we're not educating
our kids we had government shutdowns
badly spent money failures in the health
system failures in in in an extreme
amount of regulation that's why we're
going slow it's not it's not that the
economic model and I just find with
people they just they looking for simple
answers and sometimes they aren't so all
these things are fixable